alors moi depuis une quinzaine d'années
que je vis à paris il ya une troupe de
théâtre que j'ai toujours suivi avec
beaucoup d'attention
c'est une troupe dont j'allais voir les
pièces un peu comme les groupes de rock
dont acheter les disques sans les avoir
réellement entendu comme ça simplement
sur leur réputation
comédie policière luxe peine de claire
d'une chatte anglaise
alfredo arias et sa bande d'argentins
ont toujours joué
l'illusion théâtrale la poésie la magie
et j'ai toujours été très attiré par
paru aujourd'hui
arias continue puisque il alla on lui a
donné la direction du théâtre de la
commune d'aubervilliers et la première
chose qu'il a fait c'est de mettre en
scène une pièce qui s'appelle boulevard
du mélodrame et qui est inspiré de la
vie de robert macaire qui est un
personnage extrêmement important un type
social très important du 19e siècle pour
jouer robert macaire arias a appelé un
comédien extraordinaire tout à fait dans
la lignée des des victor boucher des
sacha guitry des louis jouvet ce
comédien nous a fait le plaisir et
l'honneur d'être ici aujourd'hui
il s'appelle jean rochefort
m
alors jean rochefort est ce que vous
alliez voir les pièces du groupe c c'est
durant ces quinze dernières années
oui j'ai vu luc j'ai vu effectivement la
chatte anglaise qui m'a bouleversé
d'autant plus que je les trouve un peu
héritier d'une compagnie que j'ai
pratiqué mois pendant sept ans il y à
déjà fort longtemps il s'appelait la
compagnie grenier hussenot
et ce sont un peu les héritiers je
trouve spirituel de cette compagnie et
c'est là gentil ce que vous avez dit sur
eux je crois qu'effectivement ils ont un
grand grand grand talent sur les
éditions mois d'extraordinaires non mais
c'est vrai besoin mais ce que j'ai dit
sur vous et aussi avec ce que j'ai dit
sur hyères se trouve simplement s'ils
voulaient carrias à une époque où les
gens étaient un peu déçus par là par la
pauvreté visuelle et la complexité
intellectuelle du théâtre arias est
arrivé avec une grande naïveté une
grande prenant les choses au premier
degré simplement vouloir le dire et je
suis ravi qu'il est qu'il errait le
visible et très juste il est arrivé dans
une conjoncture idéale en dehors de son
talent c'était un moment où peut-être
que le théâtre n'était plus le théâtre
il n'y avait plus la joie des émotions
première c'est-à-dire le rire les larmes
le plaisir des yeux et arias et sa
troupe sont arrivés là comme un beau
diamant dans un climat un petit peu
terne et gris voilà durait depuis
plusieurs années je vous propose une
chose savez vous êtes un scoop à la une
alors je vous ai réservé une petite
surprise sur le plateau aujourd'hui j'ai
fait venir le personnage de robert
macaire et nous allons revoir
le voilà donc voilà comment vous serez
habillé sur scène
et oui c'est très impressionnant oui
merci philippe j'avais indiqué à ce
costume si qui c'est mon costume c'est
le costume que j'aurai alors robert
mackey week-end et il s'est un peu le
père de fantômas et le père d'arsène
lupin
c'est un voyou c'est un voyou qui séduit
les dames et socialement c'est très
étrange dans ce qu'ils n'hésitent pas à
tuer
c'est un tueur en même temps mais il a
du charme il a le sens de la langue il
parle bien et robert macaire été
interprété à l'époque par un parent un
grand comédien qui s'appelait frédéric
lemaître qui était un peu un type très
insolent un peu un espèce de coluche est
ce qu'on pourrait dire c'est un espèce
de coluche du 19e siècle
milo m tel un grand acteur et puis en
plus donc il a interprété robert macaire
dans une pièce qui s'appelait l'auberge
des intérêts dont nous sommes largement
inspiré mais est ce qu'on peut dire que
le maître a inventé le mélo à une époque
où les gens étaient encore très habitué
à la tragédie classique c'est à dire
qu'il a été l'événement et qu'il a à
travers notre époque quand on parle du
mélodrame on parle beaucoup de frédéric
lemaître
mais le mélodrame existe est très
fortement avant et pendant près d'un
kilomètre sur tous les théâtres des
grands boulevards de paris lui et
c'était une tradition et mon dieu quand
on relit des mélodrames on comprend le
succès et l'impact que ça avait auprès
du public parce que c'est drôle
maintenant mais de temps en temps c'est
tout à fait tragique et étendre
écoutez moi je sais que je voulais
simplement vous demandez pour finir cs
quand ça commence que tout le monde y
aille parce que arias et vous ne méritez
tout à fait tout le monde allez voir
cette pièce alors région de sel commence
quand ça commence à levine au ventre est
bien merci beaucoup jean rochefort merci
maintenant
maintenant nous allons regarder
évidemment première mi temps du premier
match les sujets théâtre